it's been quite an eventful year now
hasn't it and while things haven't been
going so smoothly on the production side
of things for some titles let's just
hope it doesn't affect upcoming seasonal
shows some time back I made a video on
the most anticipated anime series in
2020 but since you guys like fight so
much I wanted to make another video just
for action series so why don't we cut
the list down to size and focus on the
upcoming action anime specifically new
or non sequel ones that are yet to be
released in 2020
[Music]
video game adaptations are a dime a
dozen these days so why don't we take a
look at one of the upcoming ones to
start off this list sure an echo project
zero chronicle kicks off this list this
tale set in a fantasy world revolving
around two mythical figures the white
cat and the black cat both sides fated
to wage war get into a tangled mess as
the two key figures fall in love with
each other but that's not what the story
is completely about of course our story
takes place millennia after the
aforementioned war that ravaged the land
where a hero and adventurer Kyle journey
through the world of numerous islands
meeting iris and Katara
together the party resolves to traverse
the world in order to find the seven
great ruins following cars last words
before being consumed by darkness
sounds so JRPG and so mobile game right
sure on eco project zero Chronicle
launches this spring 2020 which is a
very very stacked season honestly I'm
not liking his chances given that it's
going to be sharing a season with stuff
like rezero Tower of God and Sao
nonetheless if you got spare time to
watch a non sequel I think that this
series or to provide some entertainment
to pass the time
[Music]
taking it a far less serious tone
president it's time for battles the
second video game adaptation that we've
got lined up this time it's based game
is more of a strategy game where players
recruit and train adventurous and yes
it's an assegai
erasing any doubts that the genre is
losing momentum in coming up with new
things for the setting to play around
with this time though instead of
starring a brave adventurous set to
explore worlds beyond the horizon this
series of folks are feeling more related
to something like those GM modes or
simulator modes you see in video games
with a trailer that's already been
released the show seems to be one of
those comfy shows that you can watch in
order to unwind the character design
looks good and the premise lends itself
to something light-hearted and fun up
next at number eight is man another show
bound to get lost in the shuffle of
spring 2020 the eighth son are you
kidding me yeah
judging by the title you guys already
know what this is about the story's
basically about your classic salaryman
sleeping and waking up to find himself
in another world seems that truck guns
services are constantly decreasing in
demand with these a Sakai characters
finding ways to waltz into parts unknown
without the need of getting run over
this time our protagonist finds himself
inside the body of a six-year-old who
turns out to be the youngest son of a
poor noble family the boy Wendelin
Vaughn Benner ball Meister looks to
harness his unique gift of magic in
order to bring prosperity to the family
well based on the trailers and the
poster that we have already you can
pretty much see where this is going I'd
say that if you're up for this genre
then why not give it a shot as for me
the setting did kind of remind me of
Knights and magic which is a show I did
like in a way so who knows if I can
spare some time between watching those
awesome sequels in the jam-packed season
maybe I'll give this one a shot
finally ending the streak of video game
adaptations and it Sakai titles we have
heaven's official blessing for me it
seems as if Kings avatars big success
opened the floodgates for more Chinese
adaptations heavens official blessings
the next in the line of Chinese web
novel adaptations and it takes us back
to the classic historical setting
featuring the staples of ancient
kingdoms and the realm of gods the
series stars Shelley and crown prince of
his kingdom who was once ascended to
heaven at a young age hundreds of years
after the event he once again a sense to
heaven this time as a laughingstock
determined to shed off his negative
reputation he begins his first task as a
god one that brings him a fated
encounter with a mysterious demon who
brought the ghosts however there seems
to be more to this meeting than meets
the eye
and it might have been years in the
making all along judging from the poster
it also seems primed for some bromance
down the line for those of you who like
action stories with a dash of boy love
here you go seems that we get remakes so
often now that I think is becoming
almost a staple for every season or two
to have one of them this time our lucky
winner for a modern remakes the anime of
the much-beloved RPG Dragon Quest Dies
Great Adventure is set in your typical
JRPG world where the great battle
between good and evil has since finished
the Demon Lord has been defeated by the
heroes and peace has come to the island
that since been teeming with life
needless to say evil does soon resurface
and this time it doesn't seem like the
previous heroes would be enough to stop
him our modern-day hero die now takes it
upon himself to put an end to evil once
more scheduled for October 20 2010 Quest
dies great adventure reminds me of those
good old sordid magic shows of the 2000s
kind of something like a Final Fantasy
or beat the Vandal Buster if you guys
are old enough to remember the latter
made
at the halfway point we take a look at
an original anime gb8
20 30 Japan the hot spot of a virus
infection man this series is ahead of
its time as uncomfortable as this
premise can be considering current
events anyway 2030 Japan is frankly a
hellhole one where the virus has turned
people into monsters depending on their
status in life the virus is
appropriately named GBA have no fear
though as time-traveling samurai and
ninja are on their way coming in from
the early Edo period they fight together
with a doctor who's trying to find a
cure for GBA facing off against threats
from all angles this ragtag band seeks
to survive and find a way to end the
plague in Japan overall the anime does
look really stylish and it will surely
be filled with action now whether the
stylish player would only be what they
are is yet to be seen with GBA set to
release this July we don't have too long
to wait for this one
studio width is at again with its next
project the original anime great
Pretender first unveiled in anime expo
2019 great Pretender looks to be a
unique anime revolving around the
concept of con games these con men make
their rounds all over the world doing
what they do best while having their
dangerous adventures life can be a
dangerous game and Adamawa Masato and
his partner Kudo are out there living
life on the edge
based on what we know so far great
Pretender looks to be one of the more
realistic anime out there the action
will be there but it'll be more subdued
I think the main attraction for this
anime is going to be the play on
mortality the crisp art and the comedy
aspects of it I thought these are con
men we're dealing with here only that
they go after the bad guys to studio
wits made an aim of attack on Titan and
the several attempts at cloning the
blockbuster like carbon re and Ser up of
the end but great Pretender looks to be
a nice daring attempt to something just
a little bit different only time will
tell if it will recreate the magic in a
different way
[Music]
we start off our top three with a bank
featuring a much awaited anime
adaptation of one of the biggest web
tunes from Korea God of high-school god
of high schools come a very long way
first premiering in 2011 as a webtoon
basically a webcomic god of high school
and the proliferation of webtoons in the
english-speaking market seems to be
intertwined almost a decade after its
initial launch it seems fitting that it
would finally get an anime adaptation by
mapa god of high school is about jin
mori a 17 year old martial artist from
korea cocky and headstrong he claims to
be the world's strongest fighter his
days of glory would come to an end when
he encounters a blond man who then
invites him to a martial arts event
called the god of high school
predictably jin gets knocked out by the
blond man putting his ass in its place
and showing him that he's got a very
very long way to go nonetheless there's
no mountain that can't be scaled and
Jin's foray into the world of martial
arts truly begins now do you think
that's going to be it for webtoons that
are slated to become anime think again
or my roommate Pierrot to follow up we
have the number two spot being occupied
by another hyped Korean series knobblies
if you've been a fan of Korean webtoons
for a while
surely you'd have heard of right and the
nobles in one of the biggest Korean
series that's out there after getting
some adaptations of sorts in the
previous years we're finally getting a
full-length TV series of knobblies long
story short knobblies tells the story of
your overpowered vampire character who
finds himself in South Korea after a
centuries-long slumber setting off to
find his loyal servant Frankenstein
right
our main character enrolls in a school
where the former is the director in his
attempt to adjust to the modern world
being the knobblies and pretty much the
most powerful noble vampire back then
that task might not be the easiest ones
to tackle for our protagonist with a
huge fan base backing it up knobblies is
set to be one smash hit that will take
the anime world by storm there is one
problem though it's not even the most
hyped korean anime that we have coming
up after all we have this next title
topping the list yes the only one that
can match knobblies in a list like this
is one of the few series that eclipses
it in popularity 25th bombs story of
scaling the titular tower of god has
captured the hearts of many webtoon fans
both in and out of Korea scaling the
tower while holding onto the chance to
reunite with his friend 25th bomb braved
the deadly tests and the perils that
await him on each floor the main
question for me is how far they'd go for
this adaptation with Tower of God easily
being one of the longest series out
there with some of the most amazing
world building around I think that it'd
be a shame if we were to be left hanging
in the anime adaptation with everything
else considered Tower of God looks to be
up for a strong debut set to premiere
this April its prime to go toe-to-toe
with the onslaught of sequels to popular
series and I'm sure that everything
coming together will make the April
season a major blockbuster to look
forward to now that's quite a list isn't
it if you ask me my takeaway from this
is that there's a lot of shows based off
non-japanese materials that are showing
a lot of promise it looks like the world
is slowly catching up and I think that
it would only be a matter of time before
Chinese and Korean titles and
on the same level as the ones from Japan
that we've all grown to love with all
the sequels of popular series headed our
way in addition to those titles the rest
of 2020 looks to be an amazing year in
terms of anime don't forget to leave a
like and subscribe if you haven't
already for more anime updates and I'll
see you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]
[Music]